[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm david solyani creative
director of mariplas rabbits sparks of
all
i'm very pleased to welcome you to this
showcase today to reveal more about our
game last year we announced that we were
creating a new adventure in the mario
plus rabbits universe a unique and
colorful world born from the encounter
of mario and the rabbits
and we have been hard at work to craft a
journey a tactical experience like no
other
i know many of you have been waiting for
a hole here to get more information
about the game
so let's dive into it
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope takes
place in a whimsical galaxy the result
of the merge of mario and rabbids
universes
[Music]
but this galaxy is in danger
as cursa a dark entity wants to absorb
all its energy
its influence has spread all over the
world
and is made visible by darkness
cursa has also sent its minions to
capture the sparks
born from the merge of lumas and rabbids
[Music]
sparks are almost defenseless against
cursa
but mario and his friends will come to
their rescue and save the galaxy from
this terrible threat
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
delve into many worlds and environments
in your quest to defeat cursa
and have the freedom to explore those
worlds as you wish
[Music]
throughout their journey mario and his
friends will meet a cast of
unforgettable characters
some of them will give you missions to
complete
[Music]
those quests are the opportunity to
explore worlds lush and brimming with
content full of challenges to overcome
and mysteries to uncover
[Applause]
new allies will join mario and his
friends in their quest
some are eager to join the fight
some
not so much
even bowser joins the team in an effort
to reclaim his lost army
[Music]
but curses unexpected minions will stand
in their way to protect the galaxy and
save the sparks heroes will have to be
brave and they will have to fight
[Music]
make your way through a whole host of
battles
lead a team of three heroes you select
control directly and move in real time
in tactical dynamic battles
use a variety of tools to navigate the
battlefield
flank your foes
and find opportunities to thwart them
[Music]
adapt and use all the tools at your
disposal
including your enemies
[Music]
each hero is equipped with a specific
weapon
from handy double shots
to flashy explosive projectiles to
dazzling melee attacks
they all offer complimentary play styles
once the heroes finish their turn it's
time for the enemies to step up
make sure to take cover to avoid attacks
because your foes won't miss an
opportunity to take aim at your heroes
each of our heroes has a unique
technique
shield your allies in battle
prepare a devastating counter-attack
or put your enemies to sleep
techniques will always prove useful if
used in the right context
[Music]
each battle one will grant experience
points to the team and the heroes will
level up allowing them to grow more
powerful
in an intense battle mario and his
friends can count on the help of the
sparks
each hero can harness their powers in
battle
sparks open a whole world of tactical
possibilities
clever use of their abilities can truly
make the difference between defeat
and victory
teamwork is key to gaining the upper
hand
use all the tools at your disposal to
set up devastating combos and win
difficult battles
this was just a glimpse of the journey
that awaits mario and his friends
where the end of a quest is always the
beginning of a new adventure
[Music]
meet enchanting and enduring characters
face powerful enemies during epic
encounters
[Music]
find the sparks and save them from cursa
embark on this great adventure
for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
that was a first look at this adventure
with more surprises to come
you will be able to uncover the full
scope of the game when it releases this
upcoming fall on october 20 2022. we
like to call it a tactical adventure as
you will be able to experience a totally
new kind of gameplay with real-time
action and strategy at the core as you
just watched you will be traveling to a
galaxy in trouble accompanied by your
team of heroes with the freedom to
explore new planets
help their inhabitants and save the
sparks along the way
but most exciting of all you will lead
your ears during action-packed tactical
battles helping them content against the
evil cosmic tractor
cursor
the battles are truly at the core of our
game we wanted to go crazy with the
combat system beyond what you usually
see
in the turn-based genre for instance
there is no grid on the battlefield so
you can directly control your heroes in
real time during your turn
plus you will be able to harness the
power of the spark whose powers allow
you to customize your playstyle
speaking of the team
last year we introduced two new
characters to our unusual party of
heroes
first there is rabbit rosalina the ever
jaded rabbit
really different from her role model
and then there is this mysterious new
habit with this world
her name is edge
i hope you will like her as much as we
do
many of our beloved heroes are back as
well
each hero truly follows a unique
archetype in battle that you can use at
your advantage for instance
luigi shooter skills allow him to eat
harder the further away he is from his
opponent
we can't wait for you to explore all
their unique abilities but we still felt
our lineup was incomplete without a navy
hitter and so today we are happy to
welcome bowser to the team
it's unexpected of him to team up with
his longtime rival so you are probably
wondering why he does so
well i do not want to spoil the fun
surprises ahead but i can tell you that
it has something to do with cursor in
its destructive pursuit to extend its
reach to all planets this malevolent
entity has taken control of bowser's
army
now bowser has no choice but to join the
ranch of the rabbit's heroes and fight
alongside mario to reclaim his army and
it will be explosive
with this last edition our roster of
ears is now complete however there's
even more surprises for you today
music has always had a huge place in
mario plus habits
it is especially important for making
the games planets feel alive
and the battlefield tense
and we need exceptional music scores to
create this
so i'm very happy to confirm the return
of my dear friend the super talent gran
kilcop as a composer for mario plus
rabbit's sparks award but he will not be
alone this time as we have assembled an
exceptional crew of talent from all
around the world
he will be joined by god cooker and
yokoshima
two phenomenal composer that i'm beyond
proud to have now on our journey
i hope you are as excited as we are
about what we show today we cannot wait
to unveil more surprises in the coming
months
with maripos rabbit sparks of all the
development team at ubisoft is bringing
lots of new and exciting ideas to the
world they are inspired by nintendo's
revered creativity and that's why i'm
mapping to introduce a special guest
welcome takashi-san
konichiwa
nintendo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
b
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you